- DRock start 34 with this one.
Missed my flight by two minutes
so now I'm in a back of a car
and I have to drive
five and a half,
six hours to Charleston
and it's already midnight.
Actually, it's not midnight, that's good,
I'll get a little sleep, but it's 9:50
and I gotta be on stage at
9 o'clock in the morning
with six hours of driving
because I missed my connecting
flight by 120 seconds.
You know, the glamorous
life of an entrepreneur.
It's all champagne,
bottles and models.
The big life.
Houses and cars
and watches, right?
My ass.
- [Voiceover] Round of
applause Charleston everybody
for Gary Vaynerchuk
everybody, let's hear ya.
(clapping and cheering)
- Morning.
- How you doing?
- Super duper well.
- I had an awesome
meal last night.
Beer, wicked pasta, pickled
ramps, what'd you do?
- I missed my connecting flight
and drove five and a half hours
from Atlanta to Charleston
and got here at 5am
and drank some bullshit
coffee in my hotel
and ready to rock
and roll this morning.
Ready to go.
It's almost life when rap got big.
Everybody just decided that
they're going to be a rapper.
You can't just decide you're
going to be an entrepreneur.
You can.
There's a big difference
between being an entrepreneur
and having entrepreneurial tendencies
and actually being a
successful entrepreneur.
I think a lot of people have been
extending their college lives
and disguising it as entrepreneurship
and are losing a lot of people's,
I worked fucking hard
for my money.
I came here with zero.
I didn't have a single
fucking vacation day
or weekend since I was
in the seventh grade.
I'm not pumped about
losing my money, right?
I'm not a VC like everybody else
where I made money on the carry
because I went to Yale
and then Bain and McKinsey
and I grew up in
an elite environment
so I was able to start
a venture firm.
When I lose money, it hurts me hard.
$100,000 is more money
than my fucking dad made
for the first 10 years
he was in America.
This isn't a joke to me,
so no, I do not feel bad
for the businesses
on the other side
and I'm really looking forward
to dead fucking carnage
and complete fires and
death in this space
so that we can recalibrate what
the fuck we're talking about
because the audacity
to think that something
bad happened to the business person
in an environment where they
took normal people's money
who are going to get all
pumped up about the jobs act
because CNN and FOX
are going to have to
talk about something
after the fucking presidential election
and everybody's going
to find their fucking
zucks and travis
and you're going to put
in $5,000 on a website
and it's going to be the
next fucking Facebook
and you're going to make
7.8 million dollars.
It's going to fucking terrible.
- Gary.
- Yes.
(clapping and cheering)
- You just told a
crowd of entrepreneurs
they're going to fail,
the apocalypse is coming,
give them one bit of positive news.
- No.
No.
And I'm going to tell you why no,
because if 24 year old
me was sitting up there
here's what would be happening,
fuck this old dude.
I'm going to fucking navigate,
build a big fucking business
and I can't wait to email
this fuck face in 10 years
and be like, yo,
I was in Charleston
when you were doomsday-ing,
I just built a 100 million
dollar business, bitch.
Cause that,
cause that,
cause that is what
an entrepreneur is.
They don't care what
your mom thinks
what your friends think,
if it's cool, if it's not,
they can't breathe.
They have to build their thing
and they have the
confidence regardless
of somebody before them
says it's going to
be good and bad
because a real entrepreneur
can absolutely navigate
through the toughest times,
that's when the best
businesses are built.
A lot of the great companies
that we talk about now,
Amazon and Ebay were navigating
through the shit, right?
And they navigated well
and built great companies.
I'm proud that I built Wine Library
when it was completely
wall street centric,
high end wine during a collapse
on wall street and 9/11.
It was very hard how
I built Wine Library
and Vaynermedia was
built in 2009 and 10
when shit was bad.
So, if you're so good,
if you're so great,
if you're so gonna be the person,
I have great news for you.
Shit's about to get bad
and you get to prove it.
- Gary, you're great.
- Thanks.
- Crowd, you guys are great.
Thank you very much.
- Thank you.
Thank you.
- [Gary] You want a crush it line?
Crush it.
- [Voiceover] My name's Peter Kaftka,
I'm a senior editor at Re/code,
I cover media and technology
and I've been doing
some version of this
for more than a decade.
In 2007, I was the first
hire for a company called
Silicon Alley Insider.
The idea, originally was we
were going to cover a lot of
New York tech businesses,
it ended up pivoting
into a bigger focus
but for awhile, anyone who
did anything in New York
that had anything to
do with internet 2007,
we would be interested in it
and it was a pretty
small group of people.
David Karp founded this little
vlogging thing called Tumblr.
We were all interested in Twitter
because it kind of seemed
like a New York company
even though it was based out west,
then one of those
guys was Gary V
who was this guy who
turned this wine business
into an online wine business
and was becoming an online celebrity,
it was a very new novel thing,
so we were all interested
in what Gary was doing.
Kind of seemed like
a novelty at the time,
a lot of folks,
probably myself included,
figured alright,
this is a novelty,
he's going to move
on into something else.
So, it's pretty impressive
nearly 10 years later
there's now an entire Gary V industry.
Good job, Gary.
- It's great to see you again.
- Hi.
- Margaret.
- Margaret, how are you?
- Good.
I'm going to put you,
which one do you want Gary in?
- Let's go left.
- OK.
- Left?
- Or for me, it's his right.
- How much lighter are
you since last year?
- A lot.
- You guys talking dieting tips?
- Because of that man.
Yeah, right there, Mike.
- There you go.
- Can you help me?
- Where's that one coming out from?
- This one's DRock.
- That one's yours.
- I want the streets to love me,
I want that trenches to love me
which is why I'm attracted
to the south
and female entrepreneurs
and minorities
and so I tell them every
time, consistently,
and I don't like saying
it as a white dude
that made it in America,
but it's true which is if
anybody has ever made it
that looks like you,
then you can too.
And what's harder, much
harder than getting money
or respect from the establishment
is actually winning with the market.
When somebody will say to me
well, Gary, I can't get
funding because I'm a girl
or I can't get funding
because I'm from Mexico.
I go, bro,
bro, it's way harder to
actually have your product win
with customers
than to get some old white
dudes on Sandhill Road
to write you a check.
So, if this is breaking you down,
if you're crying now,
you're in deep fucking shit.
- The market's the ultimate validation.
- The market makes old
white dudes that are racist
seem soft.
- Last question.
- I like that.
- I like that, yep.
- I like that, DRock,
make sure that's in there.
But, do you understand?
- I do, yep.
- If you're crumbled
by what the media
or what VCs are
giving you an at bat,
you have no shot in the
reality of the marketplace.
- Right, because if you
can make it work
they're going to follow you.
If you've got the idea,
you've got traction,
you're making revenue,
they're coming to you.
- Of course.
They don't care.
That's what's so
great about Capitalism.
Capitalism can be so fucked up
but the second you have
the leverage of success,
they'll be the first in
line to say they're sorry
and write you a big fat check.
- Well, we love you and
you're always welcome.
- Thank you, brother.
- Thanks, Gary.
- That was interesting.
This is a salty, salty day.
Salty V is in full effect.
- How are you, sir?
Good to meet you.
- Nice to meet you.
How are you?
- I'm great.
- So, what are we doing?
- What we're going to do today
is we're going to freeze Gary the action.
- Oh, this is Snapchat,
you have 10 seconds, go.
- Oh my god.
Then we're going to do light painting.
- OK, too late.
We're going to continue.
And then what?
- And then we are going
to use a LED light,
200 little LED lights in the background
and paint a big geometric pattern
in a 30 second exposure.
- Bam.
- Boom.
Your spot's going to be right there, yep.
A flash is going to go off
and then you're going
to have to be a statue
for about 30 seconds.
- Oh shit, OK.
Wait, wait, you want me to
stand still for 30 seconds?
- You can move around a little bit.
- This might be the greatest
challenge of my career.
You could've literally said, hey,
you now need to become a
navy seal in two hours,
go and save this hostage
and I'd be like, OK,
that's more doable
than what I need to do right now.
But, I'm going to try.
D-rock, does this look wild?
- Alright, my friend.
Rock and roll.
One, two, three.
(slow hip hop music)
You're super tack sharp,
but all this motion in front of you
are the LED light.
Look there, some stuff going on down here.
- That's really neat.
- G, can I do a selfie
before you leave?
- Yeah, of course.
- Awesome, hey,
nice to meet you, man.
- Awesome, thank you.
Thank you so much,
thanks for having me.
Ooh, real love.
Thank you.
- We've got a great room
upstairs for the book signing.
- Awesome.
- It's gorgeous.
- Awesome, how are ya?
- So, better than last
year inside than outside?
- Oh my god, last year was.
First tweet I see.
No one in New York gives
a fuck about Charleston.
Oh, boy.
It's so interesting though,
I'm not coming from a bad place.
- Of course.
- I come from a good place.
- Gary V.
- Hey guys.
So, so far, pretty good day.
Lot of good stuff, right DRock.
What was interesting?
- [DRock] The market is the market.
- Yeah, the market is the market,
it's a really good story.
I think a good title for this one might be
if anybody ever made
it that looks like you,
you can too.
Right, I've been saying that a lot
or something to that degree.
I really believe in that.
I love how people are more
scared of the pre-market
than the actual market.
They're more worried about why
nobody will give them money
and how hard they have it
as someone who's a minority
or a small segmentation
and there's so many examples of it,
race or gender, but there's also
I'm from the south and I can't,
the market is way tougher
than the white dude
VC establishment
and we need to start recognizing that.
If you're crying that
you can't raise money,
then the market's going
to eat you up real quick
and so, the other thing is,
you should take that as an advantage
to actually build a business
that isn't predicated on raising money.
This is your opportunity to
go in a different direction
and build a tangible
business that makes money.
There's a lot of places
to get money from,
you don't just need them
from venture capitalists,
you can get them from
so many other places
and so, yeah, it's what I think.
- Generation.
You gotta jump on it.
- That's awesome.
- Cool man.
- Hey, DRock, you wanna jump in?
- Yeah, get in here DRock.
- Let's get a picture.
- Let's get you in the middle.
DRock in the middle.
So, egotistical DRock.
- Cool.
- Awesome.
Yes, I do.
I don't know if you
can make it out,
but that's what I do.
- So, check this.
I'm launching my Soundcloud page
for my music production and everything
but I wanted just to ask you,
doing everything with social media
and hit up all those small blogs.
- Yes.
- Like I know Nick Guarino
and all those guys,
I'm just curious if you
know of any other methods
that I can market myself.
- Get awareness for it?
- From the start, because it's hard.
- I think Twitter search is killer.
- Yeah?
- Yeah.
The kind of music you're making,
you know the terms,
just like I know about
wine or the Jets,
I'll give you a good
example in Jet talk
because then I think
I'll give you what,
if you search Molden on Twitter,
you're going to get a deeper Jet fan
than you're going
to get if you search
Brandon Marshall, got it?
- Yeah.
- So, what you need
to do on Twitter
is search those kind of terms
and then literally just
engage with somebody
and be like yeah, I love
his work or her work
and they're going to be like
who's this guy that likes it
then they're going to look
at your Twitter account,
your Soundcloud's
going to linked, got it?
It is the number one way
when you're at zero to win.
To spend five hours
a day just jamming
with people that
have like interests,
they become aware of you
because you talked about
things that you both like,
search hashtags on Instagram.
So, somebody puts out
some love to an artist
that does similar stuff.
You leave a comment, it's the
only person that comments,
and you're like yeah, her shit is rad,
and they're like, who's this dude?
They click it, they
click your link, got it?
That's 100% what you should do
and by the way, you should
start doing that now.
- No, I will.
Been putting everything together.
- Do I have two minutes for this guy?
- Yeah, absolutely.
- OK, let's do it.
I love you, brother.
- See you around.
- Going to see your dad tonight.
- Yeah, have fun,
I wish I could be there.
- Actually, you know what,
let's take a photo for your dad.
Love it.
- Alright, brother, be well.
Good seeing you.
- My name's Fernando,
this is for Sustain
Creativity's Digital Idea Train.
- Love it.
- And you seem to be
a digital idea master.
What do you think about that?
- I think I'm a master, yes.
- So, I'm over here
and can you tell us a
little bit about your book?
- Yes, sure.
I wrote a book on the
state of the union
of being an entrepreneur
and a digital,
social, internet marketing guy.
People get confused about
the value of content
versus the value of context.
I'm not going to say
very many things
for the rest of my life.
I've got four to six
basic things I believe in.
I'm just very very good
at making it contextual
for the day that we live in
every single day.
The end.
And that's what I'd tell you to do.
- OK.
- Right?
I can write this book every year.
I can write this book every
year for the rest of my life
but it's all in its
religion, in its religion.
It's going to be the same.
- Yes.
- But, in its tactics,
it'll be different.
It's because I want
to affect the youth
with at least,
I don't want them to think like me,
I don't want them to idolize me.
I just want them to hear me
to use my message against what
they hear from other people
because I think I'm in the
minority of selling hard work
in a world where
everybody wants it now
and I just want them to
have my voice in their ear
along with all the tricks and
the secrets and the systems
that I think they're
getting pounded with
on Instagram and other places.
- [Fernando] Well, that's great.
That's great advice,
I'm sorry.
- [Gary] No, no worries.
- [Fernando] If this is not
too much to ask,
could you sign a
couple of my books.
- [Gary] Of course,
let's do it brother.
- Ah, you're the man.
- No worries, man.
- Gary.
You said hi to my Snapchat fan,
but you didn't say hi to the Youtubes.
- I love you Youtubes,
I've been doing since '06.
- 10 seconds of advice.
- Don't listen to anybody.
Not your momma,
not this guy, not me,
just listen to your heart.
- Do whatever you want.
There it is.
- You guys grew up
with all this stuff.
I'm old.
We didn't have
Youtube or the internet
to do practical things
around what you love
and you can and that's serious.
- There it is.
- [Gary] It's funny that the
theme that's breaking out
in today's episode is
the market is the market
is the market
and it's ironic that it's happening
on one of my favorite leisure days.
I mean, literally, spending
a boatload of money.
You guys all talk to me about
why don't you fly private
because I never want
to spend the money
in a business context sometimes.
I keep it frugal
but because the NFL draft
is one of my favorite days of the year.
I'm flying because I
need to get to AJ's house
in time for it, that's
how much it matters to me.
It's funny, this whole
market is the market is the market thing
is so real.
So, I look at NFL players
that are NFL ready
first rounders today.
They've been analyzed
by all these scouts
and all these pundits
and people are judging
where they should be taken
in the 32 picks of the first round.
No different than a bunch
of VCs analyzing businesses
and one of the themes
that have been coming up
is I'm trying to tell people, look,
if you think it's hard
being a minority
or from a small town
or a female entrepreneur
and nobody's giving me money
and you're crying about that
and you don't realize
that that is much easier
than what you're
going to deal with
when you're product
actually goes to the market
and the market takes
over and decides
then you're not a winning player
in the same way, that today,
32 guys are going to
get drafted to the NFL
clearly this quarterback
that's going to be taken
number one and two,
there could be another
quarterback or two
taken in the first round.
All the pundits, all the
experts, all the analysts
is saying that these
are the two best
but then the market takes over.
Then, these four guys
or three quarterbacks
that get taken today,
have to actually go on the field
and they have to play
and then no matter
what everybody said,
oh, Bill Polian, 40
years of NFL experience,
if he's wrong because
he judged you without
knowing what happens
when you hit the market,
you get to stick it to him
or he's right.
That's the bottom line.
At the end of the day,
all the talking, all the
challenges beforehand,
all the kids that
came from small towns
without a dad or their parents
got killed in a car accident
or whatever it may be,
that have now made it to this point,
no matter what it was.
Or the private school
kid on the offensive line
that came from a rich family
and had the easy way right to
Michigan University to play.
It doesn't matter
how you got there,
now you got to this moment,
then you get picked,
the market says your
the 18th best player,
but you can be
the first best player.
If we redrafted Von Miller's draft,
I bet you he'd get
drafted earlier, right?
I don't think Tom Brady slips
to the sixth round of the NFL draft
and it kills me to say that.
I don't think Russell Wilson,
I'll go there, makes me feel better.
I don't think Russell Wilson
goes in the third round
of the NFL draft
if we do it today
but that's because
it hit the market
and so what I'm imploring
entrepreneurs to do
is to not cry about all the reasons
they haven't been
able to raise money
in a world where
that is not the market.
That's the micro-market.
The actual market is when
your business sees earth
and has to win or lose.
The amount of
overhyped businesses,
because of the pedigree of
the founders or the idea
that have happened
over the last decade
that have failed is enormous
and all of the business
that nobody thought
would succeed have.
By the way guys, I yearn for this.
You know I preach what I live.
You know how exciting it was for me
to go into the agency
world on Madison Avenue
where all these
big agencies existed
and everybody's
like the wine guy
who has a couple of
followers on Twitter
thinks he's going to
start a social media shop
which we don't even know
what social media is,
it's crazy, it's crazy to me
how delicious all
that negativity was
and now sticking it
right in their mouth
over and over and over again
as I build one of the biggest shops
is so exciting for me.
Do you know how easy
it was for me to just,
just how insanely easy
it would've been for me
to just be an investor in 2010?
- What do you mean?
- Just have a fund.
Do you know how
easy investing life is?
It is, yeah.
Now look, you have to be unbelievable
to get to that moment in your life.
- But, don't you have to perform?
- Yes.
- What would happen if you
if from 10 to 14 the fund didn't do great?
- First of all, you would've
had a four year vacation
where you getting paid a lot
of money for doing nothing.
You know the economics, right?
You get 2% of the carry,
you reach $50 million
and you're getting a
million dollars a year
and you have 200,000 expenses.
Even if you don't crush it,
you make $800,00 a year
to meet people
and give them money.
Number two, if you don't win,
it's been stunning to m
e how many people
can go out and raise
money from the next tier.
Maybe you can't get it
from the best people.
Doing.
The reason I just said to you,
I get mad when people don't realize
how much of my own dog
food I actually eat.
When I'm like, go work, go work,
build a business.
That's what I've done the
last six, seven years.
I went and built a business,
a meaningful business
and I did it during good times.
It's actually harder
to build a big business
and a good business
when it's easy to not have to.
The next decade's going to be about
building actual businesses again.
So interesting.
And so interesting because
when everybody
is going to be forced
in the next decade
to build businesses,
I'm going to be investing.
It's unbelievable how counter
cultural I am in all aspects.
- [DRock] You have to be.
- I have to be for me.
I'm so anti-establishment.
I so do things that are not scaleable.
When things are too
good, I go the other way.
I make it harder on myself.
That's interesting.
I'm going to make a lot of
money in my 50s and 60s, a lot.
I'm going to buy the Jets.
I see the pattern recognition now,
where I didn't at 30 when I
looked at myself in the mirror
where I don't have the wealth
that even makes it conceivable
for me to do that now.
I see the patterns.
I've learned, I've learned
30 to 40 what I needed.
I feel very accomplished.
Forget about the money.
- What about 40 to 50?
- I'm gonna make a lot in 40 and 50 too,
it's gonna be really interesting.
I see it very clearly.
I like it.
I've said it before, people
crying or complaining
is the quickest tell on
a non-winning player.
The entrepreneur that
tells me how hard it is
to be raising money and
how unfair the market is
and how they, I need your help Gary
and that losing mentality
doesn't make me feel very good
about how they're going to succeed
when they don't
get enough downloads
or when they don't
keep enough customers
or when their marketing didn't work
or when their right hand
man quits on them
or when some company copies,
they copied my app.
Put your head down and execute.
Everything else will work itself out.
It's incredible.
Boy, there's a lot of stuff I can't have.
Pretty angle.
- I know, it's totally
fine if you don't want to,
but just throwing it out there.
- Looking for the angle, I know,
I do that to Lizzie all the time,
but usually mine's more like
Nate's coming over in an hour.
Hey, handsome.
Hey buddy.
(slow music)
What the fuck, Ari?
- He's a wonder wick, he's an idiot.
- Wonder wick.
- He's stupid.
I'm not going to yell at Gary,
I don't want to yell that.
- Just wanted to make sure
you're still in the room.
- I'm super in the room.
I'm in the room, Mike.
- [AJ] Pretending to
have him before the draft.
- [Ali] Do we need more glasses?
- [Voiceover] Fitzpatrick, right.
- Alright, Nate.
That's your first take,
you know it's a Snapchat,
get your shit together, go.
- Got a rustic nose here.
- Rustic nose?
- A little sour cherry.
- What do you think, Phil?
You like it.
Ali?
- Lot of tannins, good mid-palette.
- You're drinking water?
- H2O, baby.
- Guys, can you believe
little Lou's a good employee?
You know how many
times I get reports
that he's doing well?
I laugh out loud.
How is this happening?
- He's being responsible.
- Little Lou, he gets
all this good feedback,
do you laugh when
he gets good feedback,
I laugh.
I feel like they're joking
because they know I know him.
- So do I.
- AJ, did you see this?
You're going to shit
when you're about to
hear what happened.
- You're all talking about Hack, right?
- No, Tunsil.
- But, it's about a-hack, yeah.
- Got sued by his dad?
- No.
- That's true by the way.
- Someone tweeted a video of him
smoking out of a gas
mask on his account.
Literally, this happened
10 minutes ago.
- [Gary] He may drop out
of the first round.
Right now.
- How do they know it's him?
- [Little Lou] Watch till the end.
- He takes it off at the end?
- But, what's wrong with that?
- [Gary] Are we sure its weed?
- What's wrong with that.
- Did you see what Snapchat did?
- People are killing Gruden.
- They are?
- Off carries, but yeah.
- Nope, just in general.
I never smoked weed.
- [Voiceover] The Tennessee Titans
with the eighth pick
in the 2016 NFL draft,
the Tennessee Titans select
Jack Conklin.
- Wow.
- Now, I buy it.
- See ya.
- Now, I'm buying it.
- He's like, Cam, I wanna
smoke so bad right now.
- Now you got him,
AJ bought it.
- You know what,
I'm all in on Gruden too.
Put away your Twitter.
- Put your social media away,
right because he tweeted that.
Let me tweet this right
before I get drafted,
this will be funny.
Stupid idiot.
- I hope it's somebody
we've all never heard of.
Myles Hack, Myles Hack.
- Paxton.
- I'm waiting to pick.
- [Voiceover] With the 28th
pick in the 2016 NFL draft
the New York Jets select Darron Lee.
(clapping)
- We survive.
Hack is still alive.
- We're not that excited.
- We can not take an offensive
player in the first round.
Good day.
Got a new Jet.
Hustle a lot.
It was fun.
Good stuff, DRock.
- [DRock] Another good day.
- Good day.
Welcome a new Jet
into the family
and got to spend some
quality time the peeps.
Good stuff.
(slow paced hip hop music)